مرحبًا بكم في Space scotland
[موسيقى]
أخبرنا عن عملية
تصميم المقصورة ، فأنت تعرف ما هي بعض العناصر
الفريدة
التي يجب أن تضعها في اعتبارك يا رفاق ،
تعلمون أننا نبدأ بثلاث
مقترحات أساسية للراحة والسلامة
وتجربة الفضاء المناسبة لذلك
تحتوي على مقاعد فائقة الأمان توفر أيضًا
راحة هائلة ،
ولكن بعد ذلك نملأ المساحة
بمعرفتك العشرات من النوافذ والإضاءة المخصصة
ومرآة ضخمة لدينا مرآة الفضاء في
الجزء الخلفي من السيارة
حتى يتمكن الناس من رؤية أنفسهم في
الفضاء وأعتقد أن شيئًا مثل 16  كاميرات مختلفة في
جميع أنحاء
المقصورة لالتقاط كل شيء وهل هناك
أي
عناصر تصميم محددة
تفخر بها بشكل خاص بأي شيء
يصعب حله بشكل خاص لأنك تعرف وضع هذا
العدد من الكاميرات
في البيئة بطريقة
غير اقتحامية
وآمن ولكنه أيضًا يلتقط
كل شيء يحدث
في تلك التجربة لأن هذا ما
يريده عملاؤنا ونريد أن
نلتقط هذه التجربة بأكملها
لقد كان nce يمثل تحديًا حقًا ، لكنني أعتقد حقًا
أنه تم تنفيذ مشكلة التصميم بشكل فعال
الآن مايكل ، لقد انضممت مؤخرًا إلى فيرجن
جالاكتيك كرئيس تنفيذي جديد للشركة وقبل
ذلك عملت في ديزني
كرئيس لشركة ديزني باركس
إنترناشونال ماذا يعني هذا
التصميم بالنسبة للشركة
إنه جزء مهم
من التجربة حيث يصل عملاؤنا أو
رواد الفضاء المستقبليون إلى
الفضاء وأعتقد أنه يظهر الاهتمام
بالتفاصيل التي ستضعها فيرجن جالاكتيك
في كل جزء من هذه
التجربة من وقت تسجيل الدخول
معنا
على طول الطريق من خلال
التحضير لهذا المنظور المذهل في الرحلة
، ثم بعد ذلك من
الناحية الجمالية ، ما هو الجزء المفضل لديك
من المقصورة
التي تم تصميمها عندما تكون بلا
وزن ولديك هذا
المنظور المذهل لكوكبنا
وكل شيء عن ذلك يخرج من
بحيث يمكنك أن تأخذ تلك
اللحظة
في المقاعد ، ثم تفتح
المساحة التي تعمل بها النوافذ بالفعل
سيطرتك من أي مكان تكون فيه ، لكن من
الواضح أنك ستكون
في زوايا لم تكن موجودة في
حياتك من قبل بينما تلتقط هذه اللحظة
التي تعرف أنها رائعة جدًا
[موسيقى]